S
OF CONGRESS CAN BUILD IT
PUBLICLY AND WE AWAIT A
COMMISSION ON THAT.
BRIT HUME IS A FOX NEWS SENIOR
CLINICAL ANALYST, WE ARE HAPPY
TO HAVE HIM JOIN US TONIGHT.
I THOUGHT WHEN THAT JANUARY 6TH
HAPPENED, IT WAS BAD, I HATED
WHEN PEOPLE BREAK STUFF
COMMISSION PROVIDED A FEDERAL
BUILDING, PERIOD BUT THE
DISPARITY IN THE WAY THOSE
WRITERS WERE TREATED IN COMPARED
TO THE WAY THE RIDERS LAST
SUMMER WERE TREATED AS TOO MUCH,
IT'S MAKING ME FEEL LIKE EQUAL
APPLICATION OF THE LAW IS DEAD.
>> IF THIS WERE COVERED THE WAY
THE RIGHTS OF LAST SUMMER WERE
COVERED IT WOULD BE DESCRIBED AS
MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
I THINK TO A GREAT EXTENT IT WAS
PEACEFUL, THE PICTURE THAT YOU
HAVE SHOWN OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THE CAPITOL BUILDING MILLING
AROUND, THE GUY WALKING AROUND
THE SENATE CHAMBER -- MOST OF
THEM WERE PEACEFUL BUT SOME
OBVIOUSLY WERE NOT AND THAT
EXPLAINS THE NIGHTMARE
EXPERIENCE THAT THE UNDERMANNED
AND OVERWHELMED CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICERS WHO TESTIFIED THEY HAD
TO GO THROUGH.
SOME OF THEM OBVIOUSLY HAD A
TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE, THERE'S
CERTAINLY A DISPARITY BETWEEN
THE WAY IT'S BEEN COVERED AND
RESPONDED TO POLITICALLY AND THE
WAY THE MORE SERIOUS RIDING LAST
SUMMER WITH MORE DEATHS TO SHOW
FOR IT HAD BEEN TREATED.
>> Tucker: 70 PEOPLE WERE SHOT
IN CHICAGO THIS WEEKEND WHICH IS
TWO DAYS AGO, 70 PEOPLE.
I WONDER IF ADAM KINZINGER WILL
CRY ABOUT THAT OR MAYBE NOT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ABOUT HIM.
I WONDER IF THERE HAS EVER BEEN
A GREATER DISPLAY OF NARCISSISM
ON CAPITOL HILL AND THAT'S
SAYING A LOT, EVER IN HISTORY.
>> I HAVE NOTICED IN THE
REACTIONS OF SOME MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND SOME FORMER MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS WHOM I'VE SPOKEN TO
ABOUT THIS, VERY INTENSE
PERSONAL REACTION.
THEY ARE THE ONES INCLINED TO
CONSIDER THIS INCIDENT, THIS
RIOT IT WAS AN UGLY BY IT TO BE
SURE, AND DISTURBING.
THEY CONSIDERED IT AN
INSURRECTION.
IT WAS AN INSURRECTION THAT
FAILED PRETTY SPECTACULARLY IF
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS, WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THE EVENT THEY WERE
TRYING TO INTERFERE WITH, WENT
OFF LATER THAT DAY.
IT WAS DELAYED BUT THAT WAS ALL
THEY DID, THAT DOESN'T STRIKE ME
AS CLOSE TO OVERTHROWING THE
GOVERNMENT WHICH WAS A LOT OF
PEOPLE CLAIM THESE RIOTERS AND
INSURRECTIONIST'S TRIED TO DO.
>> Tucker: DOES IT SURPRISE
YOU THE CAPITOL HILL POLICE
APPARENTLY, THE PERSONAL
BODYGUARDS OF THE NINE STATES
CONGRESS HAS A BUDGET THAT IS
MORE THAN TWICE THAT OF THE
ENTIRE CITY OF ATLANTA AND MORE
THAN $100 MILLION THE ENTIRE
CITY OF DETROIT ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PLACES IN THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE?
WHAT IS THAT?
>> I GREW UP IN WASHINGTON AND
LIVED THERE MOST OF MY LIFE.
IT IS THE MOST POLICED CITY IN
THE UNITED STATES WITH MORE
DIFFERENT POLICE FORCES ACTIVE.
YOU HAVE THE D.C. POLICE,
CAPITOL POLICE, A VERY LARGE
FORCE WHEN IT'S DEPLOYED WITH
EVERYBODY OUT.
YOU HAVE THE PARK POLICE WHICH
IS NO SMALL FORCE EITHER, THE
FBI, THE UNIFORM SERVICES,
DIVISION OF THE SECRET SERVICE,
YOU HAVE THE AQUEDUCT POLICE YOU
HAVE THE U.S. MINT POLICE, IT
GOES ON AND ON AND ON AND THE
TOTAL BUDGET FOR IT HAS GOT TO
BE ABSENTLY STAGGERING.
IT DOESN'T QUITE SURPRISE ME
THAT CAPITOL POLICE BUDGET WOULD
BE LARGE, WHAT IS SURPRISING IS
THAT SO FEW OF THEM WERE THERE
AND READY AND FULLY PREPARED TO
MEET THE ONSLAUGHTS THAT CAME IN
THE AFTERMATH WHEN THOSE PEOPLE
WENT SCREAMING DOWN TO
CAPITOL HILL.
THERE'S A LOT TO BE INVESTIGATED
HERE ABOUT WHY IT WAS THERE WERE
SO UNDER ARMED AND UNDERMANNED
BECAUSE HAD THEY BEEN PROPERLY
DEPLOYED, WE CAN ALL AGREE THESE
PEOPLE WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN
INTO THE CAPITAL AND WHAT
HAPPENED WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: NOT A SINGLE MEMBER
OF CONGRESS WAS INJURED.
MORE THAN A THOUSAND AMERICANS
HAVE DIED SINCE THEN, MAYBE THEY
SHOULD'VE SPENT MORE TIME
WORRYING ABOUT THE REST OF THE
CO